[Music]
so I guess just a little bit of agenda
slash setting uh we're not trying to
build a parallel Society in Zanzibar
we're trying to empower existing
zanzibari Society uh and kind of our
Approach at the charter cities Institute
is to work within existing institutions
structures and figure out how to empower
people that have been marginalized that
haven't had the opportunities to tap
into the global economy tap into
International Trade networks to
Effective Education networks and allow
them to have sustained uh economic
growth so we've got a slideshow but
before we start maybe we'll go around
and offer a handful of introductions my
I'm Mark letterer um but let's go in a
few words each hello my name is Eva
Claus I'm a researcher at the Africa
Urban lab Bas between uh zanar Tanzania
which we'll talk about in a bit and
Washington DC I was formerly at the
charter cities Institute and most
recently I helped co-organize zalu which
is the the pop-up City that we'll be
discussing as well so thank you for
having
us hello I'm chance I work at safe doing
and plumia doing research product design
and a few other things um and in my uh
side Adventures personal fun time I do
research for Popup villages
I'm Casey I'm one of the co-founders for
lemonade uh which is an onchain human
coordination platform think of it like
onchain events meets onchain Facebook
groups built on web3 Primitives with a
web2 ux and uh one of the co-initiators
of zoo grma which is uh a popup Village
looking to turn into a permanent node
bringing vitalic vision of zalu to India
and making it more inclusive uh for the
Indian population thank you great not a
click see if this
works sweet oh that's not the right one
let's go back okay so first why zabar um
kind of got uh with the charter cities
Institute a lot of our work focuses on
Africa because there will be one billion
new Urban residents over the next 30
Years so there need to be new Urban
spaces built and much of Africa um has
governance that could be improved
uh governments tend to have fiscal
constraints and often have regulations
that stifle investment and economic
growth we ended up in zanar two years
ago or so two and a half years ago where
we were invited by an entrepreneur who
was a driving force behind silicon
Zanzibar and in that time kind of we
started working with that entrepreneur
started working with a developer that's
building a new town just outside sanbar
City that's in a special economic zone
and then Evan and I attended Zoo connect
I guess last year I attended zalu and
kind of we had this idea for this uh
popup Community um in zanbar so the high
level question of why Zanzibar it's a
beautiful uh tropical archipelago right
like gorgeous beaches white sand
turquoise water on the east side of the
country that's some of the most dense
kite surfing I've ever seen I've spent a
lot of time in the Caribbean as well and
Zanzibar is better than the Caribbean on
almost every margin uh just in terms of
uh like excitement culture sharing uh a
lot going on additionally Zanzibar has
been a historic trading Hub so the
people of Zanzibar are used to the idea
of Commerce of of trade of interacting
with other cultures it was even the
center of the Omani caliphate for about
20 years in the 19th century the uh uh
uh the the the the uh sutan moved uh not
califate sultanate the sultan moved to
uh Zanzibar and then when died as two
suns kind of split up one was in zanar
one was in Oman it moved back
additionally one of the challenges with
kind of attracting Talent is the
connectivity of infrastructure and
Zanzibar because it's a very popular um
uh vacation destination has a good
airport very good flight connectivity
daily flights to uh the Middle East to
Istanbul to France to zorich um so it's
fairly easy to get there even though it
is a relatively long
flight Mark talked a bit about the
charter cities Institute and uh at the
Africa Urban lab our our mandate is to
harness rapid urbanization for human
prosperity and economic growth and so
across Africa you can see this huge
urbanization Trend right it's the final
wave of of urbanization and Humanity's
history and Zanzibar is no exception so
the town is currently 800,000 people the
whole island is 1.8 million and in the
next 20 years it's expected to double uh
and and the doubling of the population
will correspond with a much larger
spatial expansion so in the core of the
city in Stonetown it's a UNESCO world
heritage site so it's protected uh and a
lot of the growth is on the outskirts
and increasingly creeping outwards so uh
with the with the city expected to
double a lot of urban sprawl a high
level of informality it's difficult for
people to access jobs uh Economic
Opportunity doesn't increase and you
kind of get this stagnant unproductive
Urban growth um so along the path of
urban expansion for stone town it's
expanding Northeast and South in kind of
these three tendrils and the entire
Southern Peninsula the fumo peninsula
has been turned into a special economic
zone and identified as the by the
government as uh a node to focus on for
urban expansion so that when the city
does meet this new Urban node in the
South it is still productive and and a
bit more Oran organized than how Urban
growth is proceeding so far uh so that's
the that's the impetus for the special
economic Zone a bit south of ston toown
which is where fumba town is
located so kind of I guess reiterating
this point
um uh the fumba free zone has existed
for 30 years it has a lot of potential
but a lot of that needs kind of the
right pieces in place to maximize that
potential so what we're kind of the
charter cities Institute one of the
things we've done is we've partnered
with the Zanzibar investment promotion
agency which manages the Zone helped
them uh develop a strategic plan uh for
for fumba zone as well as other zones as
well as promoting zanzibari investment
and the kind of long-term goal is to
figure out a model to basically right
the government owns all the land in the
zone but like many governments in the
global South they have significant
resource constraints um and so figuring
out how to partner with them where the
revenue stream would be basically
splitting land sales or or leases and
bringing in private sector actors to
build infrastructure to help with
investment promotion to help with uh uh
uh the development of the zone kind of
the way to maximize its potential
because a lot of the challenge is when
you have informal settlements they won't
have clear roads so it'll be very hard
to create Transportation networks in
them um they are uh kind of reforming
them into uh successful Urban
environments is is very difficult after
the informal settlements exist and so if
it's possible to create the structure to
allow the informal settlements to come
in to an existing structure both with in
terms of governance as well as physical
infrastructure that can set the stage
for much more successful Economic
Development over a 10 20 30 year uh time
Horizon so the fumba zone is also
expected to become a knowledge Hub um so
I think it was last year was the the
first year that the Indian Institute of
Technology which is one of the the
premier institutions in in India opened
its first overseas campus about five
minutes away from fumba town in the uh
special economic zone we're also I
mentioned work for the Africa Urban lab
we're opening up the East Africa
headquarters for the African School of
economics in zantar and the African
School of Economics was founded by
Leonard wanton who is originally from
benine and he's a professor of political
economy at Princeton University so the
first campus was opened in banin and
then expanded to Nigeria and they've had
a huge success with with student
outcomes I think they've placed over 75%
of their graduates in either top us
universities or uh development
multilaterals so it's it's a a huge
project and the clustering of of
universities in fumba uh will hopefully
serve as a a strong anchor tenant for
future growth in the in the
peninsula so uh we've been talking a
little bit about fumba town this is a
picture you can see it's kind of got
beautiful sunsets uh fumba town is
developed by CPS uh they're a developer
they have 60 hectares total of land
they've developed about 30 hectares
they've got 700 units built um they're
currently un under construction on
another 700 units depending on the time
of the year there might be 700 residents
maybe 400 but kind of averages out to
about 500 residents a year there's four
restaurants a grocery store and it's got
a very I don't know wholesome kind of
nature you see kids playing in the
streets it's welld designed so there's a
lot of people walking back and forth to
restaurants to the supermarket there's a
restaurant everybody goes to dinner and
there's a lot of like table hopping
where you see your friends another table
you go uh say hi so it's it's kind of
got a a one wonderful fun fun vibe about
it so all of these elements come
together in a very interesting way right
you have a special economic zone you
have uh a city at risk of stagnation
that needs some sort of impetus for more
economic growth um and you have this
this new city that's being developed by
a private very competent developer
called CPS and so Mark mentioned that we
both attended zuc connect he attended
zalu and so we thought that with this
kind of storm of forces fumba town would
be a very interesting location to host a
pop-up City and so the purpose of zenzal
which is the the pop-up City it's what
we we called it um is to help catalyze a
growth ecosystem in the new town kind of
use that as a shilling point for
bringing in very talented individuals uh
not only from Tanzania and East Africa
but but from all over the
world so we hosted zalu 1 earlier this
year uh as I me it was a zalu spin off
we had about 800 attendees come through
so we had various partner events which
brought in a couple hundred we had about
200 students come through for student
weekend and startup weekend and then we
had a two-day entrepreneurship day with
300 zanzibari entrepreneurs and we had
about 25 to 30 long-term residents
including both of these both of these
guys over here um so the dates were May
15 to June 21 and we had five it was 5
weeks long
five tracks digital public goods Charter
cities given that the charter cities
Institute in a special economic zone um
blockchain Tech and art and
culture so kind of the way we think
about right the title of this talk was
developing a growth ecosystem and what
excited me about zalu and some of the
spin-offs is not right having really fun
events with a lot of your friends where
cool happens right that's fun
everybody likes that but how can this be
used for more transformative long term
change and that's kind of what we want
to zanzo to be what we want to help um
uh on the margin that we can what we
want to help Zanzibar with and so we
kind of think about this in terms of
like three different legs of the stool
for this growth
ecosystem Talent governance and
culture so right the last 50 years has
basically seen kind of on some margin an
increasing cluster of human Talent if
you look at the US right like the the if
you want to do Tech you end up in San
Francisco if you want to do film media
you end up in La you want to do policy
DC Finance New York biotech Boston and
right these these increasingly focus on
these really high potential Talent
clusters is important right now in East
Africa uh Nairobi is kind of the default
Talent cluster if you're really smart
and ambitious in East Africa you
probably end up in Nairobi we think
sansar over a 20 to 30y year time
Horizon might have the chance to arrial
Nairobi on some margins right it has
kind of good underlying conditions in
terms of well-connected airport
reliable infrastructure at least for
many parts of subsaharan Africa um uh
kind of an existing Talent Network
that's emerging but has high potential
very high quality education institutions
and so one of the focuses last year and
this upcoming year was to bring
entrepreneurs from Dar Salam bring
entrepreneurs from Zanzibar bring
entrepreneurs from Nairobi right mix
them with uh uh the relevant kind of
talent that they might be able to learn
from and so one example is during I
think it was student weekend or maybe
startup weekend right like I was giving
a talk and most of the zanzibari
listeners didn't really care because
their first language is Swahili I'm a
foreigner they can't learn from me um I
mean they can but right like it's it's
the social distance is high so when we
got a uh entrepreneur from Dar Salam on
stage all the zanzabar students picked
up right they were like oh this is
somebody I see as my peer I'm going to
listen a lot more closely like that
person is who I want to be in 5 years
and 10 years and right figuring out how
to transfer this knowledge for the local
context in order to kind of get this
openness this culture this
experimentation out in the
world yeah so a couple just to kind of
talk about the the pictures here because
I think that they're they're quite
important so the one to the far I guess
my right your left um are some of the
judges and the winners of a pitch
competition that we held for uh local
Tanzanian entrepreneurs so in the middle
is James Colum he won for a lead which
is a a micro health insurance startup
that he's working on and he has this
product called mendas Salama which is uh
a compression pack for pregnant mothers
after they've given birth who are who
are bleeding so a local Innovation that
has you know they they've done some some
research on it they have a couple
published papers it's it's been very
successful so we are really excited to
have to have him and and other
colleagues participate in the in the
pitch competition in the middle here we
have vitalic giving a talk to students
at
IIT and then we have Michael M the
Krishna who's a a cultural evolutionary
scholar um talking about why humans are
so different from other animals so just
some of the the fun uh people that we
had come in through
zalo so the second pillar is governance
so capitalize on flexibility to Pioneer
new solutions to governance problems so
I mentioned right we're we're in a
special economic zone in a new city
where the the private administrator has
uh a high degree of control over uh
what's going on in the city and we're
also on a semi-autonomous island off the
coast of Tanzania so we have a lot of uh
interesting governance Dynamics within
the city but also a high degree of of
flexibility the um administrator in the
city is very open to uh some in real
world experimentation with onchain
offchain governance um maybe setting
bounties for various projects around the
city and uh kind of testing out some of
the the solutions that we've all been
talking about because institutions have
to collide with social and cultural
Dynamics in order to to Really test them
out we can build them digitally but the
second they're applied they take on a
very different life um so that's
something that we're especially
interested in and focusing on on this
year is getting some very talented
governance projects into fumba and
testing out how they work in the real
world yeah and I think culture is a
really important aspect
right like if we look at the cultures
that are very successful um uh Silicon
Valley for example has this like General
openness this curiosity this willingness
to test new ideas a lot of other
cultures might not be have those
Dynamics and so figuring out how to
incubate this progrowth Pro technology
culture an important aspect is
celebrating uh local Builders local wins
figuring out how to give them platforms
how to introduce them to potential
funders to potential mentors uh to
really Empower them we had some
conversation ations uh with students
about like oh I had this idea to do X
right how do I get funding for it or how
do I get the next stage how do I think
about what the next Milestone is and
right now just because zanar is a
relatively small island right this
ecosystem is in its emergent phase um
and so it feels good to be able to have
an impact and have a meaningful steer on
the cultural trajectory of this kind of
emerging growth
ecosystem uh and and I think part of
this is also right zanbar has a unique
culture there's heavy African influence
Arab influence Indian fluence and this
is a culture that I think Zan zaris are
proud to share to the world so give them
an opportunity to showcase right their
unique culture the the things that that
they value and that other people might
might be excited to to share with
them so we are in the early stages of
planning for zenzal 2 the the dates will
be June 18th to July 21st uh we
mentioned the the pillars of talent
governance and uh culture so our tracks
for this year Loosely uh have place a
heavy heavy focus on governance and
Entrepreneurship so zones and Charter
cities digital Nomads immigration and
visas Dows and alternative institutions
and then Tech ecosystems especially how
to build a tech ecosystem in in Zanzibar
so yes you're welcome to join us uh
zenzal dorg if you're if you're
interested in learning more and this is
our our team so Mark and I are here uh
fer de Fu she's a resident in fumba town
she's one of the leaders with Cube
accelerator which is the only
accelerator in Zanzibar so she's very
well connected in the local uh
entrepreneurship ecosystem uh Patricia
was formerly in fumba town she now
splits time between fumba and Nairobi
she works for dream VC and is very
plugged into the Nairobi Tech scene and
then uh Michelle she is an artist very
interested in web 3 has created nfts
actually made a an nft series called
zany cat for zenzal one uh so she will
be helping organize as well and if you
want to get all feel free to reach
out you're welcome K
Bo so you get to see those sunsets every
night um I think yeah uh we've got I was
gonna right we invited Casey and chance
because one they attended Zan zalo I
think we'll do about 10 minutes of
questions for them then open it up to to
the audience and both of them I think
have interesting perspectives one and
zzo and then two Casey has developed
lemonade which has become kind of the
ticketing and more platform for a lot of
these uh popup Villages that are
happening and chance has visit a lot and
is kind of The Unofficial official
Anthropologist for a lot of these uh
Papa villages in terms of visiting them
taking notes on them uh doing interviews
with attendees to see what's working
what's not working and like right we see
ourselves in a part of this larger
ecosystem of how do we build kind of not
not parallel societies per se but how do
we improve places uh around the world
how do we kind of figure out how to
change the trajectory of culture
slightly change the trajectory of
innovation right change what the kind of
status hierarchies are in a way that's
positive progrowth and leaves everyone
better off so maybe with that uh chance
if you want to speak a little bit to
your experience with zalo with other
pop-up Villages what have you seen work
what have you seen not work right how do
you see this space
evolving just to give a little more
context I think I've been to seven so
far in the last year maybe more and I've
done around it's 145 interviews as of
this morning
um I'm trying to think how can we talk
about it with this I think there's
there's different characteristics of
them there are different types so uh for
zalu it is uh you could think of
comparing them amongst these different
ones very interesting and that it's in a
basically a startup Town it was a very
interesting symbiosis to explore there
whereas the town is interested in having
them there whereas if you're in a major
city it's not that particularly
interesting for them I mean it is
interesting some will be interested in
it but it it's not a big deal for them
overall if you're a massive City uh at
least early on for a first one so and I
and I think smaller places are
interested in experimentation and these
communities that's a huge value prop any
place where they can go and experiment
and that seems to be open these
communities are very interested and they
they want to go there so I think that is
a really something something I'm I think
is promising and I hope see more of as
projects go to these places that where
there's just a good kind of mutual
beneficial in theory um play there that
could be you could learn a lot from um
so that would be one
point I think that's all that comes to
mind for
now and Casey you've uh worked on
lemonade which a lot of the papa
Villages are using as their kind of
payments app as well as more how have
you seen I met you last year at at zoo
connect and we kind of talked a lot
about this but how have you seen this
kind of these I don't know
emerging parallel societies emerging
kind of uh ecosystems how has that
influenced how you've kind of thought
about rolling lemonade out like what
tech to deploy how do you see the the
tech part of this kind of scaling up to
help with the human coordination
aspect I think
like so one of the data points also
shows that whether it is
web 3 web 2 doesn't matter web 2 kind of
user experience is what is needed when
building any kind of Technology what I
love
about zalu and popup Villages or parall
societies as you get to actually
experiment a lot with different kind of
high leverage Frontier Tech uh where you
don't get these ecosystems in the
overall web two space what I loved about
zalu was there was a lot
of um local involvement in
planning uh the entire experience and
giving access to locals to all kinds of
exposure about this kind of Frontier
technology so just for context I'm very
cynical when uh in the Western World we
talk about defi because it means
something very different in Africa
something very different in Asia where
you cannot trust your government you
cannot trust your Banks you can't even
trust the Western Union cuz there are
gangs outside waiting to mug you the
moment family from from outside of that
country transfers you any money so their
defi actually has real applicability and
real use cases so being able to build
Tech which actually gets used in such a
way so when we talk about like for
example onchain coordination it's not
really trying to come up with acronyms
like Dows erc's eips nfts these acronyms
actually mean nothing to the overall
industry or to the consumers around the
world
so kind of making this technology more
human and more applicable is kind of
like the learnings I have taken from
this also an interesting data point so
even if you can do onchain ticketing on
lemonade people who work at protocols
also they buy tickets with a debit
credit card so like in like we can come
to all these different conferences and
talk about l2s l3s and still complain
about where's the mass adoption so from
that point of view I think even within
the industry if we have to default to an
easier option of making payments we
still use our debit credit cards but at
these different popup Villages you get
to think about what is when venmo for
web 3 and what should the user
experience be so it's adoptable while
still catering to the web three
principles of self- sovereign money
permissionless Commerce sensor resistant
information
so Casey following up on that I think
two of the more interesting questions
about how I think of the interaction of
web 3 with zanzu and other POA Villages
is one right like if you go back 30
years or so and you asked will I buy
something from a stranger on the
internet everybody would say no and that
problem was solved like 100 times over
first kind of by eBay and all that was
needed to solve it was basically
reputation mechanism right was the
product approximately what was
represented online if so five stars if
no less than five stars
and that worked very effectively um and
kind of when I think about uh using this
technology right right now for example a
lot of the crypto space and the the
pop-up City space still has a informal
reputation mechanism right like you get
introduced to somebody by your friend
they're like this guy's cool he's legit
you talk to them a bit you figure out
okay is this somebody I want to work
with collaborate with Etc um but I think
there is a way to perhaps codify that a
little bit more effectively I don't know
what it is but as they're we're in this
kind of semi High closed community right
with a million different interactions
happening every month like what does it
look like to kind of scale up a
reputation mechanism can lemonade be
used for that and now because I have a
very bad short-term memory I'm also
going to ask a second question to make
you deal with my bad short-term memory
the other kind of question is um in a
lot of kind of lowincome countries the
it often have high inflation Zanzibar
for example there are uh uh what's it
called um Capital controls so sometimes
zabara uh in Tanzania there aren't
enough dollars to go around and this
hurts right like any large transaction
will be priced in dollars so if you want
to buy a house often times you want to
buy a car it's dollars but this really
hurts like the small Merchants the
smaller entrepreneurs because they don't
have access to uh uh the ACT market rate
of US Dollars and so if I think about
what the best use case for crypto in a
lot of these places is it's kind of like
stable coin for allow to allow for uh
monetary transactions in a way with a
currency that has a reasonably stable
price that has a bank that's not going
to ask for 15 different forms to
withdraw their money so part of the
challenge there is like how do you roll
out how do you get engagement from these
local Merchants like what does that look
like so first one was on chain
reputation right yes okay um so the way
I the way I see it is try and make the
in
attention as neutral as possible so like
how how we like joke about it internally
is like a chat group with a bank account
so you can decide where you want to
deploy your Capital whether it is to buy
land whether it is to support someone
within the
community um on
consensus and then in terms of building
reputation
um what we do is basically Bally
creating a social graph on chain so
depending upon what events that you're
going to and how engaged you are with
different communities who invited you or
how did you invite other people into
this community it's all committed to an
onchain social graph where people can
permissionless build their own
reputation systems that get uh like CU
even reputation is very local um whether
to a community or to a geography so I
try not get too much into the intention
side of it but more make it as
permissionless for anyone to start
building their own local products on top
of this what was the second question uh
stable coin adoption all right so stable
coin so currency in any all money is
made up as long as there's
consensus for a local community to be
able to from the entire spectrum of the
supply chain from producers to
wholesalers to retailers to Consumers
to come up with some form of consensus
on what they will bter against that's
essentially where money also came from
so
like whether it's a stable coin
centralized or
decentralized preferably decentralized
because then because even usdc any uh
Circle can Blacklist your tokens at any
point um but as long as the medium of
exchange has enough of a consensus in a
hyper local space and then scaling that
hyper local consensus to as much of a
global scale as
possible which would be like Bitcoin
would be an example or ethereum as a
store of value or store of money would
be an example so it's just getting as
many people to adopt that currency to
exchange products goods and services
that makes sense yeah but you work for
Uber and it's not just saying more
people have to adopt you need to
actually like go out talk to them what
is the go to market strategy um okay so
Supply Supply comes before demand um get
enough suppliers in this space whether
it is suppliers of land suppliers of
agricultural products suppliers of
groceries and the demand will
come that's like Marketplace economics
101 so unless we we can keep getting as
many monkey jpegs distributed as we want
come up with as many erc20 tokens as we
want but
if no supplier is willing to accept them
to offer you products goods and
services it it's not going to bring any
adoption and chance um like what excites
me about zanzo and also like Cento I
think is in this bucket and what zalo
was is this potential for long-term
change is this partnership with the
local community for those that don't
know cres Mento is the popup in
Argentina um that's trying to get kind
of special economic zone in Tech
regulation pass there's a moment in
Argentina obviously with Malay and
there's a very active uh web 3 Community
there and so that's kind of what excites
me about uh these these experiments is
that long-term impact is figuring out
how to slightly change the growth
trajectory of a of a city of a country
of a region um but chance you're
spending a lot of time visiting these
like what what gets you excited what
causes you to do all these interviews
right like you're dedicating substantial
amount of your free time to these these
these experiments like what what's so
interesting about it for you I think
originally before I started researching
this I was researching the history of
mutual Aid uh and the history of
associational forms basically how humans
have aggregated in history um and when
they aggregate they uh can solve problem
shared problems I just find that very
fascinating um so when I first heard
about zuu I had been researching also
digital Nomads remote work this sort of
thing and this is kind of a massive of
people that are atoms floating around if
you looked at them if you had a magic
wand you could see them as a network uh
of nodes there' be very few links
between them um which I think is odd and
kind of unfortunate and that's also
somewhat dangerous for them there's a
lot of uh uh you learn when you learn
read about the H Mutual Myst history of
mutual Aid is that social ties informal
safety nets are really important um so I
just generally believe that's important
that social ties are important for
humans and this sort of thing so I
gravitate towards places that
potentially could provide that so that's
why I gravitate towards the pop-up
Village model now shifting more to
individual jurisdictions or places one
of the things that I think really
excited me to the point that I am
continuing you know at the 145th
interview or this sort of thing is I
think there's a there's a reasonable
hypothesis that these public Villages
which you can think of as aggregations
of humans in a way um could meaningfully
help inject dynamism or unlock dynamism
in jurisdictions most countries in the
world are used to losing brains not
gaining brains and now with remote work
and this sort of thing countries feel
like they can compete you can use the
number of digital Nomad visas which is
something 40 to 60 plus as a signal that
countries view that but I think more PR
or or practically with the interviews
you do see it come out when you
interview people who are local to that
place um and you you hear it talk about
in just ways where they just are like
excited like I can actually do this it's
being around um you can think of these
po Villages almost like distributed
Silicon Valley culture or maybe more
ethereum culture but which is very
curious very open very high agency like
build things this sort of thing and I
I'm from a small town in Canada I think
many people have a similar thing in
other countries you know that kind of
mindset is not necessarily um High
status in certain places like when a
factory farmer Place being kind of nerdy
is not uh they kind of gets pushed down
but if you get plugged into a place
where that's not only is that exciting
but it's like what's your idea okay you
should talk to this person you should do
this like that animates people and I
think that meaningfully changes things
potentially um one I've heard people
mention it in two different ways one
person at Zu Village Georgia mentioned
um uh safe harbors these things are
basically like a safe harbor for people
who are intellectually isolated and so
you could imagine you know within a
region or uh it could be within a
continent if they can fly to that place
they are suddenly surrounded by people
who encourage the kind of thing were in
their small uh you know small town or
their small group of friends even in a
major city they may not have that kind
of encouragement so you know that that I
think that's quite promising uh and
that's something that countries can't
buy like they they can't buy that kind
of thing if that can uh meaningfully
happen so I think Argentina is a really
good example just because you have such
a high percentage of locals in that
movement the pop-up City probably had 60
to 7% people from Argentina um and I
heard people say yeah I started a
company that I wouldn't have started if
this wasn't here here so I'm very
excited about that cool and then I guess
one final question for each of the
participants what are you most excited
for in the pop-up City space or with
zalu over the next
year uh I'm excited for Z Grandma I hope
you talk about zma in a second coming up
in January in India um for zenzal I'm
really interested in experimenting with
this governance component um whether
that's a residency whether that's us
working with the developer CPS to kind
of set bounties and uh get people to to
send in bids to actually execute the
bounties uh some type of creating some
type of governance sandbox in in fumba
uh we were joking earlier that we have
concepts of a plan uh for this so if
you're interested in this and uh want to
get involved with sanalo please do come
come chat with us about how to structure
uh an bridging onchain offchain
governance in in fuma town
uh for me where I I mentioned there's
there's multiple things I'm excited
about but I'll I'll just pick one for
now um playing with permanence I think
this is something that comes out a lot
in interviews people are kind of
yearning for this um you know not like I
want to move to this place forever but
be longing for more permanence in in
specific jurisdictions so people like
that it's more plugged in to local
communities there and they want that
more um and there there are a lot of
projects that are are going towards that
and there's someone named who might be
here in Argentina uh unaa who's here if
anyone knows anybody who's looking to
invest in permanence projects talk to
una um but those I think are the
important projects and and something
that I think these are the next step for
these it's more permanence and jur
directions I think like I Chan said like
especially about like what excites me
about zalu is that it's a permanent node
where you can host popup Villages so
back to China is like earlier Point
bringing a lot of talent that is cycling
through these permanent
nodes um so that excites me a lot um and
then building a holistic ecosystem of
like you can pay for your college
tuition on chain you can buy groceries
on chain you can create Community
Gatherings event ticketing splitting
payments venmo like stuff all on chain
so these kind of permanent parallel
societies where
High Talent which you otherwise have to
travel to San Francisco New York DC or
LA to kind of get access to kind of
comes in one place for a short duration
of time but when they leave they leave
rots of permanence which can kind of
grow into some really tall trees um also
on the governance side I think what's
exciting
is in the special economic zone and also
like the Indian constitution has a space
for how to create a village guaranteed
by the Constitution of India it's called
punch punch means five ayat means
government so 5% rule elected whether
onchain or offchain the government and
the Constitution doesn't specify so you
can actually experiment a lot legally
under the policy realm under special
economic zones or in India as long as
like you don't go off the Constitution
cuz back when any Constitution was
written nobody actually
knew that internet would be a thing or
whether onchain or
offchain what about you uh I'm excited
to scale up zalo one of the
conversations we recently had with the
other organizers uh was to kind of do a
um look at other startup laws across
Africa figure out how we can adopt those
laws to um Zanzibar last year for
example we had the minister of Heritage
and tourism uh speak as analu and figure
out right how do we
uh uh right start getting uh legal
Frameworks that can Empower
entrepreneurs how do we start really
getting deeper engagement with the local
universities with the the local
businesses uh how do we get like greater
Regional connectivity with our Salon
with Nairobi uh with with Europe with
other places and and really start start
scaling this up so we've got I think
about eight minutes left we'll open the
floor for questions
nice
that okay now it's working um I was
wondering if you have any insights about
um like the Local Economic culture and
if it was different the way that people
transact or or do trust between
themselves like how is it diff if if you
notice it was different than like the
the way we perceive the economy in the
Western
World um nature of transaction so mobile
money is is very popular um in in East
Africa in Tanzania and kenyia especially
Kenya has had impesa which has just
grown like a wildfire across the entire
country in Tanzania it's easy PESA and
then there was uh a locally developed
app called Nala which is very useful for
crossborder payments um the issue with
mobile money right now in Tanzania is
that savings accounts are tied to SIM
cards so if you lose your phone if your
phone is stolen that's your entire bank
account that has suddenly disappeared um
so crypto is a very viable solution to
that because if your mobile device is
stolen you don't you don't lose access
to uh your entire life savings um so
that's one big difference in in
transaction I think also uh common
savings are are more popular so groups
of people that get together and kind of
have this rotating savings pool um so I
think experimenting with onchain
Collective savings uh would be would be
very interesting as well um and and very
useful in in Tanzania and in xan more
specifically uh those are the two major
differences that that come immediately
to
mind I think there's a question over
here
uh yeah I think my question is for Casey
uh when you do these things uh which
technically sound like intentional
intention based uh do you really keep in
mind like the fact that is it about like
scaling VB Tre or scaling uh this this
idea this philosophy that is discussed
around here or is it like something
different for you inside your head
because uh you know what like comes into
your head when you try to do the good
intention scaling work because it has to
sort of like connect internally for you
to find reasons every day to do these
kind of work yeah so uh when you say
scaling you mean like for adoption for
more people to start using at least you
here you've been talking about those
things so yeah I don't know what you
personally do or like how you think
about things uh but how do you find the
connection uh between you and these
one connection from me personally is
like I worked I come from like web2 for
like 10 years up until 6 years ago when
I started building in this
space uh mostly like hypergrowth
startups so like when Mark mentioned
Uber so I was part of the first Uber 150
where if you tried to tell people that
you could call for a car via an app
which wasn't a taxi people didn't
believe you up until there was enough
supply of cars um um where you could get
a ride under two minutes and you had to
pay onethird of what you paid cabs
because even the cab industry is its own
Mafia um so when I think of scaling I
think
of not
using the acronyms which we in this
industry love to create and so I try and
use as much web2
terminologies and not try and show what
is on as web 3 Primitives
so even though for example your tickets
are nfts I don't really advertise it um
someone wants to resell their ticket and
wants to take on the scalping industry
they can build like their own products
on the protocol and then advertise it
for themselves so I think of like web 2
user experience built on web 3
Primitives better cheaper faster that's
it like if you build a good product that
provides
value Supply will come demand will come
and as long as that product provides
it's providing that value which is
better than what exists it's cheaper
than
competition and it's faster which means
it saves you time and money it'll
scale um but trying to make things sound
over complicated or extremely smart is
what alienates a lot of people to even
get into this industry and think that
it's a scam so yeah so like try and not
use web free
terminology my personal connect to this
is coming from all those hypergrowth Web
Two startups where we did a lot of
unethical stuff so everything you've
heard about Uber in the documentary is
true in the TV show is 80%
true um and it was just something where
we saw consumers they give up their data
for
convenience very
easily and that data can be
manipulated in all sorts of ways which
also this is being recorded I'm under
NDS so maybe like we can talk one-on-one
off the Record and I'll tell you about
but that's something
that I wish personally that we could
find an alternative for permissionless
Commerce and sensor resistant
information because this only matters
when the government or policy makers
turn against you so it's like that 1%
probab probility or 0 1% probability but
it's a good hedge
against potential Bad actors in the
future so if it's built with the right
principles from the start I cannot be
subpena to give up anybody's information
so that would be a like if Uber was
built on the right principles thanks
Casey we've got time for one more
question hi uh simply put we were just
wondering how we think education uh fits
into all of this in a way that we ensure
it's it's inclusive and
multi-generational education
specifically yeah um so that's that's
definitely another pillar of a growth
ecosystem right so uh to build to to
facilitate economic growth you need
human capital you need uh good
governance uh and so for Education
that's something that we're still kind
of working on we're looking for a lead
for Education last year we had student
weekend talk about African Urban lab
you're literally starting a university I
thought okay okay I thought you were
talking about zanzu specifically um so
yeah we're still looking for for an
education lead for uh for Zan Alo but uh
for the Africa Urban lab African School
of Economics we're hosting our first uh
professional diploma program in seven
days so in one week from now um and
that's going to be mid-tier urban
planners coming in from uh all over East
Africa to learn from some of the best
urban planners uh that are currently
working in the region um and and some
economists some some government
officials so um yeah I'm not sure did
that answer your question or what was
your yeah it it does uh for the most
part um I just wanted to uh encourage uh
folks to look into southeast Asia that's
why we're here right now um I'm from the
Philippines and I actually don't have an
education after first grade so the last
time I was in school I was like s years
old and I went straight to the internet
and I believe that there's more people
like me um I just want to uh let you
guys know that uh with whatever you guys
plan to do in Africa uh please do it for
us as well uh but more importantly I
plan to encourage a collaboration and if
as you said there isn't a model yet I
hate to see this um technology not reach
areas that are not U reached at all
those without internet so if we could
figure out a way to reach areas without
the internet and really make it more
exclusive regardless of their education
background I think we really uh we're
really able to um um amplify um the
technology that we're not going to have
again thank you for your answer thank
you
[Music]